clair voici donc Nicolas Sarkozi en
piste c'est l'ultime étape d'un parcours
commencé il y a plus de 30 ans une route
où il a connu autant de succès que
d'échec c'est ce qu' l' forgé dit-il
aujourd'hui retour sur cette ascension
interrompu par une longue traversée du
désert avec toujours la volonté et
l'ambition de mener la bataille
présidentielle Arnaud
Boutet porte de versaill même lieu il y
a tout juste 30 ans j'ai l'honneur de
proclamer JAC Chirac président du
Rassemblement pour la République au Parc
des Expositions jacquesirac bouscule les
chiqu politiques et un jeune homme
s'empare du micro avec
énergie ce qui nous intéresse d'Er
Jacques assumer pleinement le destin qui
est le sien et qui est grand tellement
grand pendant près de 20 ans Nicolas SAR
soutient jacquesirac il fait de lui son
maître en politique jusquen 1995
élection présidentielle le RPR se
divise
ma conviction c'est qu'Édouard Baladur
est toujours celui qui dans la majorité
est le plus susceptible de rassembler le
plus grand nombre de nos compatriotes
avec le choix baladure Nicolas Sarkozi
passe pour un traître entre les deux
tour il est sifflé par ses anciens
[Applaudissements]
amis il se fait oublier la traversée du
désert s'achève en 2002 nouvelle
présidentielle Nicolas sarzi réussi à
s'imposer dans l'entourage du candidat
Chirac 2002 c'est pour lui la
reconquête il voulait Matignon il aura
l'intérieur mais le premier flic de
France voit déjà haut très haut et il ne
cache pas son
ambition une dernière question on vient
de parler de 2007 quand vous vous rasez
le matin là vous pouvez penser à autre
chose qu'au ministère de l'Intérieur
est-ce qui vous arrive à ce moment là de
penser à l'élection présidentielle pas
simplement quand je me race un passage
au ministère de l'Économie et des
finances un retour place beauovau
partout Nicolas Sarkozi impose ce qu'il
nomme le parler vrai et en train de se
dire exactement ce qu'il dit c'est pas
mal mais s'il est en situation est-ce
qu'il le
fera malgré l'opposition de Jacques
Chirac il s'empare de l'UMP cette
machine de guerre c'est pour lui la
prise de pouvoir en même temps sont par
les vra confin parfois au dérapage vous
en avez
assz vous avez band
RACA va vous en débarrasser avec
Dominique de Villepin la collaboration
ressemble à un bras de fer mais Nicolas
sarzi trace sa route à 52 ans il caresse
son rêve et entame la dernière ligne
[Applaudissements]
droite